to the CMS colloquium this afternoon our
speaker today is Carlene Maitland
professor of Carlene Maitland who is
co-director of the Institute for
information policy and associate
professor in the College of excuse me
information sciences and Technology at
Penn State and State University and
professor Maitland's expertise includes
analyses of ICT use in international
organizations especially for those
involved in fostering economic and
social development and humanitarian
relief this next week she's headed to
visit three refugee camps in Uganda um
kind of work she does she's going in I
think she's going to tell us a little
bit more about that work but she's going
to be doing some analysis of network
infrastructure in the refugee camps her
research has been funded by the National
Science Foundation in fact she used to
work within the National Science
Foundation as a program officer right
and US aid the US Department of Commerce
and IBM among other funders during the
past couple of days Carlene generously
participated in a workshop called media
refugees and ICTs that was organized by
my lab at global media technologies and
cultures lab and the title of her talk
this afternoon did you know like why
yeah yeah I see T's for Refugees and
displaced persons and this talk is also
based on a book that she has forthcoming
from MIT press so please join me in
welcoming professor Maitland
[Applause]
great to be here this evening and I'm a
pretty informal person so if you have
any questions please feel free to
interrupt me as dr. Park said this is a
talk based on my forthcoming book the
book in the book it's an edited volume I
challenged the authors to end myself
because I also authored a couple of the
chapters to to really think about the
future of technology and what kinds of
research needs to be done to ensure that
we get equitable use of our future
technologies so it has a little bit of
what's going on now and some of what's
going on in the future I'm going to talk
here provide some background because I
know not all of you are necessarily
familiar with displacement and refugee
affairs and then I'll talk about two
concepts that I developed in the book
one being the concept of the digital
refugee and what that means for future
humanitarian action and then also
digital humanitarian Brokerage which
talks about kind of the potential future
of the humanitarian industry okay so in
order to talk about information and
communication technology use in this
context I think it's instructive to look
at what some people talk about it's
displacement life cycle or the migration
life cycle that we talked about in our
workshop the reason that I'm interested
in in looking at these different cycles
is because the information needs of
people vary significantly in different
stages so you can imagine as somebody's
trying to flee war or natural disaster
their information needs are going to be
very different from when they are in
temporary asylum and during the phase of
temporary asylum if this person crosses
an international border and if they meet
the legal
definition of a refugee they can apply
for refugee status and that's known as
the status determination phase and then
they may settle down in that host
country as some some organizations refer
to it if they cross an international
border clearly their information needs
are going to be very different at that
time than when they're fleeing right I
mean it may be similar to when you all
move to Boston right you got to find
housing you may have to register your
kids for school you have to find doctors
even in a refugee camp some of this some
of these things are still the same right
it's just life and so those needs and
those needs may differ if you're in the
city or if you're in a camp and
depending on where you are and what you
have with you what technology you
brought with you or didn't and then
finally in the final stage and and of
course let me also preface this with
this is a gross simplification because
you know people come and they go and
they come and they go there may be they
may go through the whole cycle and then
have to go through it again
I mean it's it's a very severe
simplification of a very complex process
so the last step is resettlement or
repatriation so from the potential
country of asylum someone might get
resettled to a third country like the
United States and we had in the workshop
we had some resettle refugees come talk
to us about their experience their
information needs and their use of
technology and meeting those needs or
they may be repatriated back to their
home country and so we talked about that
- about repatriation back into
Afghanistan and so all of these
different stages have different
information needs different technical
different some cases different uses of
Technology I want to talk a bit about
the refugee status determination and
registration process because it gives us
an interesting example of
the use of technology so refugee status
determination RSD is a process whereby
authorities usually the host country is
legally responsible for conducting this
process but they may nominate UNHCR to
take care of this issue for them and
this process is very interesting because
basically at that time the authorities
have to assess the veracity of the claim
of the applicant and this is based on in
some cases the assumption of an
information asymmetry right
that a refugee can tell a story which
may actually be true or not and the
authorities have to determine whether
it's true or not but if everybody has
access to all information how do you
determine what's true or not and do we
still trust the sources that we use to
trust as sources of true information in
a world of fake news all right so I
think there's going to be a lot of very
interesting developments in the area of
refugee status determination based on
growing availability of access to
information by refugees because it used
to be thought that well they couldn't
make up a story because what do they
know about what's going on in Mosul well
they could probably find out a lot about
what's going on in Mosul just with an
internet connection these days right
so then after refugee status
determination if the person is
determined to be a refugee they enter
the process of registration and
registration is where they become
formally well probably they become
formally involved in the and this RSD
system but from there on operationally
they are entered in to the UNHCR
information system and there are
every one of the agencies that work in
humanitarian relief and that work with
refugees have systems many of them
depend on UNHCR system because UNHCR
creates a registration number or an ID
number for the refugee and then
everybody and this whole network of
organizations tries to tie in to that
number similarly to the similar to the
way that in the United States they try
and tie everything to your social
security ID right so there's this sense
of this is the number that all of every
time you go to get another benefit they
want to tie it to that number this is
this process used to look more like this
right lots of pen and paper going on no
more it's rare that you would get this
situation because what is more likely as
a situation like this where the person
doing the registration is using either a
desktop or a laptop computer and some
form of biometric identification even on
children is captured and this you know
in talking to people because I've worked
with UNHCR not as an employee but as a
professor working together with them you
know they said even in a place where
it's just people are crossing over the
border and the in the woods or you know
in the middle of the desert they'll go
out there with just a laptop they're
like we don't need power we just charge
a laptop go out there with our little
fingerprint reader and capture
fingerprints so there's pretty much
nowhere that they can't do this these
days and you can go on in UNHCR has
videos of them fingerprinting all over
the world okay so then we have life and
asylum and the information needs like I
said can vary significantly and the the
collection of data from the
Fuji's continues at every turn there is
information required from the refugees
they are you know if they want to go to
the computer lab and sign up for a
computer class the organization that's
offering the computer class has a grant
from somewhere to offer the computer
class they need to report back to the
donor how many people took the class
where their positive learning outcomes
from the class right did they what kinds
of skills did they did they develop what
did they do with the skills okay so
every time you sign up for a class you
have to fill out a survey telling all
about your experience all of that goes
into a database which then gets tied to
your refugee number right if if things
work the way they're supposed to it
doesn't always happen that way just like
it doesn't happen
they have fragmented databases just like
we have fragmented databases and so
these are some pictures of refugees in
Zaatari camp where I've done some field
work making use of technology and
different and different formats these
these two are working with a GPS device
because they were involved in a mapping
exercise so we did some you know see how
we can maybe make systems where refugees
can map their own camp and make kind of
a map that's useful to them these are
just people on the street doing some
work that that they get paid for doing
in the camp through cash for work
programs making calls to coordinate work
just like we all do these are some
students in the computer lab which is
you can see up there so on the one hand
you have right all of this information
being you know I called it like we suck
the data out of the refugees and it's
just on and on and on and there's so
much data it's crazy but at the same
time the refugees themselves are
creating data for themselves right
they're making phone calls there
posting on Facebook they're posting on
Instagram I'm getting old I don't know
what slate the latest one is hopefully
some youngster Tommy you know I mean
it's it's just I mean you can't keep up
basically who knows maybe they're on
snapchat now when I went there I when my
students were saying like National
Geographic has a snapchat channel I was
like oh my god I need to retire so
they're creating this you know I mean
you see these girls what are they doing
there right I mean it looks like they're
looking at pictures maybe they're on
Instagram I don't know what they're
doing but you know clearly these are and
it's funny to how like the use of
technology is changing so rapidly and
when we were in solitary at first we
went there in 2014 and take my picture
take my picture you took people's
pictures you know and then as the
digital cameras started going into the
camp people donate more and more and
more digital cameras then all of a
sudden they or people were saying you
know my god you know don't take pictures
anymore and I'm like oh yeah I get that
mm I'm not taking any more pictures and
all right try to take them so like
either they're people we're working with
who want their picture taken or we ask
permission of course but I have this one
picture of a refugee taking a picture of
me like her whole face is covered by the
huge digital camera and and so they
start creating all their own media all
their own pictures and videos and
posting themselves and so just thinking
about these two different ways that
information is flowing and being
captured so back to the aid organization
so it's interesting what's been
happening with the aid organization so
right now there's a big move towards
digital cash programming and it used to
be that aid organization
would physically hand out food and
physically hand out blankets things are
changing and the explanation for the
changes are that we need to give
refugees more dignity and choice right
and so in Zachary camping and lots of
other places they have developed systems
that allow the refugees to get their
assistance through a card like this
which the refugees call their Visa card
yeah isn't that the funniest thing
you've ever better piece of card when
it's a MasterCard and they go to the WFP
run that's World Food Program run
grocery store and they use a swipe card
machine just like you and I do it
wherever Wegmans stop and shop whatever
you have here and that's how they buy
their food it's kind of interesting no
because there's a very vibrant food
market in the camp so you know why do we
need all this rigmarole all right if you
gave the refugees this card and you let
the Syrian food vendors in the camp of
which there are many some very tasty
restaurants I mean you know they have
restaurants there but then there would
be a problem because there would be a
lack of control right and so there's a
lot of themes of control and those of us
in IT understand very well the beautiful
marriage between control and IT right so
this what do you think this is
this space no a distribution warehouse
that's now empty because they're not
handing out food anymore this camp is
not that old
all right in a very short period of time
they went from handing out food and
having this physical space and they had
the benches over here where the refugees
would wait and they'd all queue up and
this is a camp of 80,000 people and wait
to get their food and and so we were we
were surprised the reason we were
surprised because this is prime real
estate and that camp
it's like on the main shopping street
it's like you know having a warehouse
sitting empty on Comm Ave in Boston and
you're like what the heck was this you
know and they're like that was the food
distribution warehouse so you see even
the physical impact that these changes
create in that space we also in our
network measurements found out that this
had a really good cell signal footprint
around it and so we thought I hope that
you do something that takes advantage of
that when you redistribute this space
okay when you're pushing out these kinds
of programs right when you say I want
you to have access to the Internet
because I want to push you information
on the Internet or I want to send you
money to through your mobile phone right
so in other places they say well we
don't want to use this this plastic card
we actually want refugees to have it on
their mobile phone and to use their
mobile phone which is actually the camp
that I'm going to in Uganda which is
also not very old I think it's like two
years max and there's 250,000 people
there there's that well okay we're going
to push that out to your mobile phone
well you got to make sure people have
mobile phones all right so
have started to hand out handsets and
SIM cards and handing out SIM cards is
great because now you have everybody's
phone number right now yeah not
everybody uses the sim card they're
given believe it or not they may say hey
I came from this country and it's right
over the border and I can still access
that Network because their signal leaks
over the border so I'm gonna use that so
it's not perfect but you have a better
mechanism for reaching them but also
potentially some control and so this
issue of handing out phones can in some
cases give people access which is great
but what happens when your program the
funding gets cut hmm yeah I gave all
these refugees handsets and SIM cards
because I wanted to send them SMS
messages to let them know that or some
health promotion campaign and now the
funding for our health promotion
campaign got cut everybody who was
involved in that they're packing boxes
and leaving and what happens to all
these handsets and SIM cards I mean
they're no longer supported new people
coming in don't get them and so you get
this almost like fragmentation in who
gets connected and it's it's not the way
that we all normally experience our
connectivity this is actually an issue
here in the states too there are
homeless people who get social services
and some of our social services agencies
are saying I can't believe we could cut
our costs and be so much more efficient
if we could push information out to them
via mobile phones maybe we should just
go out and give them handsets but then
again also you have funding cuts and
then you have this intermittent
connectivity right and how do we know
how many people actually have phones
when they're getting them in these very
different ways than we're used to so
just something to keep in mind
okay so remember all that stuff I told
you about the grocery store that program
changed that little card they don't need
it anymore because all the refugees in
Jordan have iris scans they registered
them right and then they said okay wait
a minute we want to iris scan all of you
so you have to come back right and UNHCR
released its data protection policy in
May of 2016 a mere 12 years after they
started using biometrics and they will
assure you that every one of these
refugees has informed consent they have
consented to the collection of their
data I'm kind of suspicious because I
heard about this like almost riot
because everybody was running to the
registration center because they heard
there where I exams being given and
everybody wanted to have access to the I
care I'm not sure that there was eye
care going on that day I'm not sure that
there's really a process right so so
anyway you know how many of you have
about a stack of cards in your wallet
that thick some of you might be sitting
on them right now right they don't need
them because guess what once we can
authenticate the transaction via iris
scan we can also debit your account via
iris scan so you don't need a card
anymore and this is the state of the art
since 2016 in grocery stores in camps in
Jordan so it's not just that UNHCR is
collecting biometric data for
identification purposes they have signed
a worldwide agreement with world food
program to share
biometric data so that we can integrate
all these kinds of systems and to whose
benefit right they will say that this is
a huge benefit for the refugees right
the refugees get identification I'm like
well until the Jordanian police are
driving around with iris scanners and
they're integrated into the database and
they can access that and then say oh
yeah who you say you are I'm not buying
it right because how does that work I
mean it might work inside the camp which
is good but it doesn't necessarily give
you the kind of identification that
we're used to like I can go I can get on
a plane with my driver's license if the
cops pull me over I couldn't show my
driver's license I'm not seeing right
now how iris scans do that but who knows
maybe there are things under but I don't
know about we'll see I can tell you that
this is very helpful for a World Food
Program right and for UNHCR because now
they have stopped a lot of graft in the
system and that graft does hurt what
some refugees right because sometimes
people were able to doubled it right and
so if they have enough food for a
hundred thousand people and 20% of them
are double dipping there's a chance that
20% will also go without and so that is
a real problem it's also a waste of
money right because you you because you
and HDR is primarily funded by US tax
dollars many hundreds of millions of
dollars in tax dollars so this these
these efficiencies do have some benefits
for the refugees but they have also a
lot of benefits for the organization's
to playing them not only do they reduce
graft they improve accountability
because now WFP can say for sure exactly
what that refugee
just at the grocery store they can do
all kinds of analyses now on market
behavior and what people like what
people didn't like which also has
benefits right I mean now we can give
refugees what they like it's not a bad
thing necessarily but it does raise some
concerns and I don't have the answers
I'd say the book just asks a lot of
questions give very many answers and so
that's something to think about
so where is all this going all right I I
suspect that not too long from now your
wallet might be getting a little later I
cannot believe that the companies that
have tried and tested these technologies
are not going to find a way into our
lives right I mean it's coming so where
is this all going for the refugees well
these are the two concepts that I
explore further in the book the first
one is the digital refugee and so the
digital refugee is a jointly constructed
person right each individual refugee has
their own story that they are putting
into cyberspace not all but many right
and if and they control the narrative of
this part of the story right this is
what they say not always because I don't
always control what people say about me
right my friends my family sometimes
they post pictures you're like take that
down you know and and so it's not all
under their control but it's largely
under their control this is also their
story about what happened before they
fled
and it'd be interesting it is
interesting to think about what that
part of the refugee persona looks like
if you divorce yourself from the
physical presence and space of a refugee
and think about just cyberspace what
does it look like what's out there what
information is available Facebook pages
Instagram accounts emails
oh no nobody uses email anymore it may
be a little bit on the other hand
there's what the aid agency the digital
footprint of all of those aid agencies
and all of the data that they've
collected not just in the provision of
services but in the monitoring and
evaluation programs of those services
what did you think about your child's
school how did you did you like the
biometric system how did you feel about
the registration process every one of
those processes has an opinion survey
and there's just so much data available
and so this is amazing in some sense and
scary and others so what are the
implications UNHCR has a mandate to
protect all right that's its core
mission all the other agencies you know
World Food Program does the food Save
the Children takes care of children I
mean UNDP does this you know there's a
whole constellation or network of
organizations that have different
mandates and UNHCR S is primarily
protection so how are they going to
protect the digital refugee right now
their primary focus is on protecting the
the side of the digital refugee that
they have constructed they're thinking
about that
my favorite question is
so how are you going to manage the data
in the Irish scan of the three-year-old
over the course of their life right
where is that data going is you know
remember I told you that that refugee
lifecycle was a big oversimplification
you know if I go to Jordan and then I go
down to Saudi Arabia but then I don't
like it there and so I borrow some money
and I fly to Germany and then I come
back and we are where is all that data
who owns it and who has the rights to it
over the life of that child so how will
they protect this digital refugee are
they going to buy cloud space right if
I'm a refugee and I arrive in a camp
with some clothes and and some personal
belongings they'll give me a shelter to
put that in are they gonna give me
shelter for my and this is this I mean
like every time I talk about it it's so
hard
people's lives are in their phones their
their whole family album the last
picture of their child before they were
killed is in their phones and these
phones are dying in these camps right
now and everywhere there are refugees
they're dying there they're either just
getting old and our ability to access
those files is getting more and more
difficult how how are they going to
protect that are they gonna are they
gonna take ownership of that is it them
who needs to take ownership of that what
happens when these identities are
personas conflict whose account is valid
right I mean the aid agencies have their
side of that digital persona covered
they they can tell you who you are right
that will tell you who you are
right but what if it's not who you say
you are whose side is valid so what
policies are needed to protect refugees
and the digital refugee and who is
responsible these are just questions I
mean you know we talked about it in the
book and I do go through in one chapter
and talk about all the different levels
because you know the UNHCR mandate is
define an international law but not
every country is a signatory to those
laws and so and and then they're also
implemented in at national levels in
different ways right being a refugee in
one country means you can work without
problem you can move around freely being
a refugee in another country means
you're you're only allowed to stay in
the camp and you can't work so refugee
policies vary significantly from country
to country and so there's a lot of work
grad students in the audience there's a
lot of work to be done here a lot of
research that needs to be done ok the
next one has less to do with the
refugees themselves and more to do with
the provision of services to the
refugees so now unfortunately that
picture didn't come out very good this
is a refugee sitting in a probably a
very recently arrived refugee sitting in
a camp despondent with his phone so as
we find refugees more and more connected
more and more accessible to people from
the outside and we have more and more IT
savvy aid agencies what role is there
for the traditional humanitarian
agencies and I'll give you a specific
example so we were working with the
UNHCR people in Amman and they said can
you help us because we have universities
around the world want to make
scholarships available for Syrian
refugees kudos right way to go right you
you understand the problem of lack of
access to higher education you want to
offer them a scholarship to come and
study in your country great but they're
they're kind of reaching out directly to
the refugees and that scares everyone
right
and so UNHCR was saying is there a way
that we can try and insert ourselves
into this process to make sure that
those offers are not only valid because
I mean there's a lot of them are
reputable institutions we assume they're
valid but that is that the people are
making the offer understand the lives of
the refugees and their issues we want to
make sure that those offers come with a
full package of protection we need those
people to explain what kinds of
psychosocial services are you going to
make available for it for these refugees
what language training or language
vetting are you going to offer what if
they flunk out are they going to get
sent back to Jordan what if the
Jordanian government changes their
policy and doesn't let them back in are
you going to keep them what happens when
they graduate are they going to be
forced to leave where can they stay
these are all really important questions
that the refugees themselves might not
be asking and the universities might not
be asking and so there's clearly a need
for people who understand refugee
protection to be involved but do they
need to be that involved what level of
involvement and so I think this this
notion of digital humanitarian brokerage
is is something that describes the
evolution of the sector and it's
interesting too because this comes at a
time when there is a lot of pressure for
change in the sector right this kind of
old-school set of organizations that are
not very tech savvy
don't necessarily innovate as well as
they might although they've been doing
quite a bit of efforts in this in this
area for the last few years so digital
humanitarian brokerage could allow a
much more diverse range of organizations
and processes to develop so how far will
that protection mandate go and how far
should it go in the cassette I mean this
can create all kinds of new
opportunities new types of organizations
we've talked about instead of refugees
being housed in camps or even given
vouchers for finding apartments you know
can there be some kind of exchange where
people who are interested in hosting
refugees you know this happened in Paris
right people volunteered to host
refugees and so the little kind of
grassroots movement and website
developed it goes along with their kind
of embrace of market mechanisms and cash
based assistance all right but I don't
know that the idea that it should just
be wide open because when people have
suffered trauma and then are in a new
country they're not the most savvy
consumers all right not everybody right
I mean we're talking generally some
people are very savvy even after all
they've been through so I think there is
also need to think about new threats and
what can happen there but I do think
that this is the way things are going to
be going because there's so many I mean
I just gave the the example of the
universities and and that situation but
there are so many of these examples of
just because of the digital cash impetus
okay so that's
basically it so if you have questions
I'd love to talk about it and like I
said I mean the book is it talks about
kind of social and information theories
in the first section and different
technologies and technical approaches at
the end and then concludes with a
discussion of policies and then these
trends but it is meant to be a research
agenda so it's something that graduate
students can take a look at if they have
if they're searching for a new project
to give them some ideas okay thank you
okay questions selling them SIM cards
and you know this I guess it ignited a
conversation since I was wondering I
mean it sounds like it's probably not
the first thing that someone makes an
outrageous decision about though it's
one thing if you had other examples of
you know things that telecom regulation
should yeah I mean there are people
governments are getting it's interesting
because in the most of the rest of the
world people have multiple SIM cards and
share SIM cards and you know the ID like
their relationship to a telephone number
is very different from ours in the
States and maybe even in Western Europe
and so countries have become more and
more concerned about not being able to
tie a number to an identity and so this
is this is creating some restrictions I
have a concern because we did an
analysis of
data in Zachary which found that when
when women share SIM cards their use of
whatsapp increases much more than men
and so women depend on sharing
mechanisms with handsets and SIM cards
and any kind of connectivity tools to
have better access overall and so when
you limit sharing that's probably more
detrimental to women than men so what
can telecom policy do some of our
recommendations that you know we kind of
posed them as questions but first of all
we need more innovative technologies so
at least that keeps asking why can't
they just build like a Wi-Fi invention
the camp whether it's connected to the
internet or not and I'm like exactly
right I mean this would be helpful right
and so then management of spectrum to
allow more I mean this this has benefits
we beyond refugee and thinking about
that you know how do we manage
telecommunications in times of emergency
what you know what are the requirements
in that case if you have normal
requirements to serve on broad broadband
operators do influxes of refugees fall
under that and and basically so spectrum
management and mandates to serve yeah
okay
more questions there's a question here
yep
so you mentioned that these agencies are
sort of attracting the biometric demon
from the innocent refugees what happens
if a refugee leaves a refugee situation
like they become a citizen through
whatever process do they get to go back
to UNHCR and say that's a good question
and to be honest I don't know if they
delete the data that is a very good
question but I will tell you this that
the the host country always has the
right to know everything about someone
who comes into belichick always has the
right to know everything but they have
rights to the data so when UNHCR
collects that data they do that on on
behalf of the host country and so they
regularly like in Kenya they were
collecting all the data then the Kenyan
government was taking over the rsd
process the refugee status determination
process and the registration process and
so they just would hand over the data
set to the Kenyan government that is the
government's data in UNHCR and all the
UN agencies in any country operate at
the permission with the permission of
the host government when you come to the
United States UNHCR is part and parcel
and mat could probably talk more about
this he's worked for the I of the
International Organization for Migration
his part and process part and parcel of
the of the refugee status determination
and vetting process so all of that data
come in to the US government and I would
expect the same in the UK so yeah it's
it's an intergovernmental transfer of
data whether they delete the record from
UNHCR I don't know I'd like to think so
but somehow I doubt it yeah
did you have a question no more
questions
oh yeah yeah yeah that is very much my
my concern and we've done some work
trying to because I've worked with these
organizations I'm like alright yeah I
can either like sit outside and LA
or I can push them so in Zachary we said
hey you guys have you've got this data
collection thing down how about the
refugees collect their own data and not
data to serve you data to serve them and
their own decision-making and so they
were pushing this asset based Community
Development approach to help the
refugees develop a sense of community
and to solve their own problems mostly
because the money was drying out and
when they had plenty of money they
didn't want the refugees solving their
own problems but when the money was
running out they wanted them to so we
said okay what if we train them to
collect and manage their own data and it
was so I won't say funny I'll say
interesting um to see UNHCR who was
funding the project they just they were
like give it if you collect it in that
way it's not going to be useful to us
and I'm like it's not about you it's
about that right again and again and it
just but it's not useful to us it's not
useful to us it's not about you so you
know we're working on it and they you
know they're buying it slowly they
invite us to go to Kigali and do it with
urban refugees there so we're we're
trying to make those inroads and that's
but that's no way refugees have an
access to the data
they've given UNHCR it's the totally
different I'm probably not brave enough
to even try that yeah I was just
wondering if printing I do and then is
there given that there's not a lot of
Irish transaction going on in
post-industrial Western want to be
democracies you know I just wonder if
this is kind of experimentation like a
testbed for a lot of these systems and
if they're being tested on people that
don't have clear civil rights because
they're in these precarious and
vulnerable in-between conditions and so
I'm just I just wonder like I haven't I
have not as I have not explored in depth
the biometric industry however as
compelling as that argument would be I
would push back on it because I know
that in in Jordan the company that is
developing and promoting that system is
Jordanian so this is more an outcome of
authoritarian regimes because that
company started selling biometric
technology to the Emirati government
back when like airport control security
and all of that so I would say that
industrially and in innovation wise that
the Middle East is a hotbed of
technology innovation in the biometric
space and it's not just for Refugees I
mean people Jordanians go to their ATM
machine and use iris scan technology for
their own transactions and this is
considered acceptable by some parts of
society and the government probably
loves it and so you know big bad
American technology
Bini pushing this on you know that that
works for a lot of things but maybe not
this one
just the idea that these camps or
refugee conditions being sites for
experimentation of technologies and
practices that might not be readily
accepted in countries that have you know
civil rights laws that are even privacy
laws as much as they're being eroded
there are there's a lot of pushback on
biometric data collection and you know
democratic states yeah I I really think
that it's more like just geeky people at
work through program who want to improve
efficiency right and who see that you
know they probably walk around them on
and see people using this technology say
hey we could use that in the camp man up
and and so and there it goes right and
then it takes off and there's a report
and this person gets promoted it within
WFP everybody says how that person get
promoted they did this innovation oh
I'll do it too you know and it just goes
I mean it's just it just goes that's why
I said it's coming I mean you mentioned
the example of women to trading phones
and how much people's lives are on their
phones I was wondering if you've seen
examples of so much octoprint like tech
entrepreneurship
the cats you know what let's say there's
someone who either like knows how to fix
phones or has like multiple battery
chargers or like adapter such that you
see examples of class or impossibly even
things that might not exist in a
situation that's not yeah I mean that's
I think we were talking in the workshop
too about the differences between camps
and how camps are managed so they're
very different similar like lockdown you
know I felt exactly was pretty
constrained but people who said I don't
know that's like a free-for-all compared
to other camps in Jordan and then if you
go to like Uganda I expect to find a
much more open you know but in Zachary I
mean anything that could be solved
through entrepreneurship and you know
would be I mean it was just you know
they were saying oh we're gonna bring in
an electricity right well you find out
that actually people had snuck in
generators and we're selling electricity
to people all over the place I mean
anything that could be solved through
entrepreneurship and so there probably
are people within the camp who are who
are doing that you know but then we talk
about okay so then there's the profit
motive right like so if one refugee
can't afford to have their memories
stored what happens to them right and so
that's and it's interesting because
that's one of the one of the challenges
that you know I was like why don't you
just let me like the refugees buy
electricity from from each other or from
you or whatever because they were
electrifying the camp and there was a
big issue with I mean it's crazy to try
to offer electricity to anybody without
any kind of mechanism to ration it you
know and we use the market mechanism to
ration it here but they say we can't
charge for services it's against the UN
mandate for UNHCR to charge for services
so whatever they give they have to give
for free and so that's
and then they look at because there are
significantly different levels of wealth
in any refugee population I mean you'll
find people with master's degrees you'll
find people who fled there and have cars
and I mean it's it's amazing the
differences right then you have people
who are illiterate living next door
which is also a really interesting thing
that you know we usually have these
separations in our society by
socioeconomic status and a crisis like
this just brings everybody into the mix
together so you see people almost like
becoming more aware of that you know
like I mean you can't people in the camp
who are like wow I'm really shocked
about how many illiterate people there
are it's like oh you didn't know that
and you're like and I was like yeah I
probably am not so aware of it in my own
country either did you know you're gonna
pass okay I thought your point about the
phones of people dying with a really
interesting point about data especially
maybe photographs of people that
families that were separated from one
another and are you aware of any
projects to try to help to store and
back up any of that data I am NOT but it
doesn't mean they don't exist
I'm just not personal I was gonna say I
feel like this is something that would
be right up google.org yeah
yeah yeah that's what people were saying
they're like god they just put it all on
Google I'm not sure I want to be saying
that I wanted somebody else make that
recommendation just being an American
I'm like okay well let we'll letter
somebody from France say that yeah I'm
going to keep the same right right and
and then also email so much of this
stuff is there you know like one of the
challenges of getting them to be able to
use the UNHCR server which is open for
people to store information on this
particular clothes or whether they have
was they were like well we don't have an
email like who uses email anyway that
they were like we don't use email so
we're like well you can sign up and get
a gmail account for free and then and
then get access to the server but it
wasn't something like for lifetime
access these people right right and this
all moving back and forth and different
carriers and different numbers you know
do you know you need a system of
universal global phone numbers and you
have your phone number and it stays with
you forever or something who knows but
because of the way the market is
structured is
okay all right I catch a plane